hello again
so today my choice will be to talk about
the opening preparation
and how we work on our opening
repertoire how we you know and choose
what lines to play
oh it depends on what kind of repertoire
you would like to play let's take for
example
with black because it's always more
complicated when you're choosing an
opening of guitar with black and against
d4 i think that if you are playing
against d4
you first have to decide and it has to
do with your chest tau
if you're going to play a narrow opening
return with just
one good openings or you'd like to have
like more flexibility then if you like
to have a more flexibility
let me give like the first example if
you're going to play a very narrow pro
you're going to play for example slav
or like on groom fruit and you're going
to play basically this is a i mean from
time to time you're going to
change with a second opening but if you
want to be more flexible when you like
like some players like michael tao for
example one of my favorite chess player
to play different temples then there is
some basic opening scheme you have to
include in the buddha because if you
don't play them
like here i'm going to show like the
neem to indian then you're giving a lot
of freedom to your opponent so after the
move
d4
knight f6
c4
e6
if the opponent plays knight c3 and you
don't play bishop b for the nintendo and
then of course you give him quite a wide
choice for example in the benoni he can
play system with f4 after d5 he can
choose between the queen's gambit lies
with bishop g5 bishop a4 or the exchange
variation in the best version capturing
immediately on d5 so you're giving him
too much of a choice in my opinion so
that's why
nimto indian is like a principled scheme
if you are going to have more
flexibility then of course after bishop
b4 you can try to form your operator and
if you want more schemes sometimes you
can transpose into a gaussian but it's
needed to play the name sweden and in my
case this has been like a basic opening
and i always has played the name
trillion because it really gives me like
a wider choice how do in the
younger years i used to play quite well
and probably it has to do also with
the next formation of return
schemes from the queen's gambit accept
it
and it's not surprised that after many
years for example one of the lines i
play
quite often is like a version of the
queen's gambit accept it why the knight
you don't see it through the so-called
vienna variation so
the thing which i wanted to underline is
that the name screen is one of this
basic scheme in which
it's needed if you want to have more
versatility and a wider opening operator
of course at the bishop b4
you have to study and to have a lot of
practice because there are many many
schemes for it
they're sharp scheme they're
more safer scheme more positional more
dynamic there is of course a3 which is
like a principle scheme
and of course then you got the good
price for the exchanging immediately the
defender of the dark squares because
you're spoiling the opponent's pawn
structure and it's like a principle
which one of these two strategic lines
is going to be is going to prevail
now after e3
and then whether it's going to be bishop
d3 knight and g2 whether it's going to
be 9g to the original rubinstein
variation
or
knight of bishop 3 you also start you
know playing in the center
you you know you learn how to play in
this very normal classical position or
for example if you want to keep his pawn
structure intact e3 and then knight g2
he gives you time in return and what i
like about this mission that you always
in most of them i play lines in which
in my own way to formulate what's
happening on the boat to keep the three
possible results on the ball
there is a line which probably is the
one i've played
like the most amount of time and this is
the light the classical wine with quincy
two there is no surprise that this was
the favorite of kablanka probably even
probably it has his name the keblanc
version but i'm not sure about that but
he used to play this line now it's also
a clash of ideas because you play quincy
two
and white is saying
okay i'm going to keep my pawn structure
intact and also i'm going to get you
know the pair of bishops
now i'm going to give you short term
factors and i am going to give you time
and i'm going to give you the lead in
development
but these are
factors dynamic factors in which you
have to use them in a very precise way
because the long term factors like good
pawn structure and pair we should you
know if you don't use the initiative in
the best way they're going to you know
to stay for
a long time on the road so on quincy 2 i
have played
like i've told this is like the most
popular the line i've played against the
nymph indian even even more than e3
bishop d3 which also have been played
very often against me
to quincy two i mainly played two lies
maybe if i look at chess base we can
fight
one or maybe to probably one game in
which i played c5 but after looking at
this line i came to the conclusion that
here
the objective with the two possible
results are two so black is fighting to
equalize he can make a joking and get
slightly worse and i didn't like that a
lot so i've mainly played after quincy
two
in many games castle a3 capturing here
b6
a very complex line
some players really like to play it with
white light the great gary kasparov it's
a very complex here they're different
pawn structures it's an interesting but
later on i mean if you play against such
solid line only one particular then you
become more vulnerable because there are
players who play only queen c2 it's a
very solid line and
you know with the
the time the change the computers became
more and more influential then it become
literally not very you know uh good idea
to play in just one line so here i
started to play in this line quincy two
another
more aggressive line which is d5 more
aggressive compared to c5 on the front
move and of course if you play d5 the
vienna vibration it makes sense to play
pission with when you don't give any
space in the center by playing d5 not
after b6 you are giving space in the
center but it's a little bit you know
more complex points like this in my
opinion
is easier to play although there are
many a lot of theory so we don't have to
kid ourselves there are a lot of theory
so i started to play d5 and i'm going to
show you
some of my experiences especially one
game which i played
to be precise in a period when actually
i was already an active chess player now
it was just occasional disturbance which
i played in las vegas and in i think it
was i think the last one of the played
against very solid maybe now his
international master he was feeding
master but around 2400
and
then i had to look one idea which a
couple of months before this game it was
played on the world rapid in 2017
between accubian
who also is one of these players who
used to to play exclusively quincy too
and okay these
uh players they usually know quite well
quincy too and against a nun and an aunt
also just like i've mentioned mayor
bertorque has played many schemes
against quincy too
and okay he came up with one interesting
idea which probably you know his team
has analyzed and i
had this idea to use it in this game of
course i get to analyze
some
different possibilities also this game
look
you know the idea look very interesting
but very sharp it was you know you need
additional work
but i thought that for this game it gave
me chances to have the three results
from the broad and i think it was a good
choice so in this game you're going to
see one of the two principled lies
against d5 one of them is what in this
game played a3 immediately forcing the
pair of bishops and the other is just
capturing on d5 and playing bishop g5 of
course always when you capture on d5 and
you fix the pawn structure
and when you change from d5 one piece is
happy this is the bishop on c8 of course
some other people are not so happy but
you can have you know full happiness in
life so after d5 my opponent play a3 i
think i've expected this for him because
i'm not sure that i've seen his game
because he and the tournaments in usa
you
virtually don't have any time to prepare
but
he had you know this kind of a feeling i
had that he's going to play you know
this line so bishop take on c3 queen
take on c3 and i had positive experience
just before i go in the in the army
which in bulgaria many years ago it was
when you had like 18 years old i played
one good victory in this line there was
no computers then again it's a
grandmaster from croatia kumbling which
i think i've played the line with knight
e4 and c5 well these they know their
interesting question then of course with
all this theory and kasparov working on
this vision some of the lines became
unplayable no
but the new idea which i brought to this
game i like it by this game of uh
and and it was just to save time on
castle
and it makes sense not because y'all
play here and it's to use in a precise
way the leading development the
temporary leading development and you
have to you know play you know quite uh
aggressively because if not is going to
evaporate and i told you what is going
to be left on the boat so that's why i
like this idea and i captioned c4 and
tried to save time on short castle
exactly this interesting
announced idea if now it's working like
now we have five years of this game i'm
not very sure because i was when i was
an active player i was not only
following
anything which was played but always
analyzing you know
games not only in my rubber principally
and of course with black you have to be
in solid with white and there is this
they do advice you can afford much more
weapons but with black
you know especially in some important
lights like nintendo you have to have
like one basic player which has to hold
on well and then you can expand so taken
on c4 queen take on c4 it's interesting
today in this twitch streams from two
o'clock somebody played against me this
move bishop g5
which here i've mentioned a bit i played
b5 and then he played very badly and he
lost it doesn't matter but here it's
good to take the pawn if not we are
going to defend the pawn that's for sure
so queen take on c4 and here comes this
idea basics so you're playing a
well-known scheme but you're not playing
with shortcut you're trying to save time
and here's the idea which i like we're
not going to go have it theoretical no
because there is no appointed on bishop
f4 the idea which i like is not to play
bishop basics queen take on c7 which is
a well known normal turret client but
first castle and then to save bish
basics here the detail is that the queen
now if he takes on c7 the pawn and d4 is
still not defended and if he includes
knight f3 take a look then we play
bishop basics and now
capturing on c7 now this well
established gives black good play so
there are some small details but of
course i expect that we're going to play
in just what happened in the game and it
even
you know got a little bit
further on
than my expectation so knight f3 by my
point bishop a6
check
the check here the idea of the check
that white gives is to you know make the
coordination of the black pieces not
ideal as they want because if they just
go back they want to play knight d7 and
then to push c5 and then you you see
that still saving time on their castle
later they start even to play here move
like a6 but it's a little bit you know
i'm going to show some
more modern novelties like micro
one but sometimes they get a little bit
further i don't know how good are they
but queen a4 makes sense no queen a4
check now you can cover of course with
the knight queen d7 you want the end
game and the end game is quite all right
first of all because you're heading
development you have no pawn weakness
and it's going to be very hard here to
keep the pair of bishops in our game
you're going to see
especially white caving and their famous
pair of bishop but you have something in
return
which is a very interesting idea this
one of anand you've got to have
something here for example it's obvious
that you have good development and
avoiding the exchange of the light
square this is going to be quite
difficult so black gear obviously can't
have problems at all white has to be
careful in my opinion decent game they
have to play carefully and precisely so
quincy two
and now is this idea queen six now later
on they came up probably some teams
working on this even with this move h6
preventing bishop g5 i think it was
another game of akubian i think with
shankland yeah it was
in 2018.
well
original although maybe goes also i have
some doubt because
don't forget when a player move like a6
well it's a possible hook he's the hook
team because when he started if he has
not custom and start playing on the king
side
the fact that your pawn is on h6 just
helps to open up the king side like
kasparov has used it quite often this
team though
he in this vision he
most of the ideas were him when he was
an active chess player you know
the incredible chess player and the
third world champion gary kasparov now
a6 maybe is a little bit too much but
okay i'm not now a specialist of this
line no so when i played this game i
look at it quite a bit
oh it's it's insufficient but okay you
don't have so much time not to look so
queen six this was the idea for them
forcing an endgame the first impression
is that okay in this end game you gotta
be you know very fast because if not
i mean the thief out now is a
problematic he's going to fianchetto his
bishop so
your chance is to mobilize the pieces
and i like this idea but of course i had
to analyze quite a few questions i had
watching this game now i'm going not to
look you know in detail this question
but just to pinpoint this question which
i had to know before this game
so a long castle rook c1
king b7 the first question is rook take
on c6 95 check knight aqua and f7 and
the good thing is that you take on d4
with a tempo and it's not a bad mission
at all for black so you can take
let's not look at it because we're not
going to get time to to show you other
interesting things about opening
operation so maya point played exactly
like in this game and there is such a
move also 95 but 95 it was a move i
really looked at it's not a dangerous
the first impression is that okay now
it's going to be very easy for white but
it's not true because black compensates
with really elite in development and
they can use it in a very elaborate way
like taking here bishop take on e5 of
course taking with the pawn is not good
because the pawn structure is an
important element
bishop take here
knight e8 and it turns out that this
late in development can be used like
here and you're going to see some other
example by this very rare backward moves
usually you don't play backward move
they're usually a sign of
the something is not very well in this
piece but here
this is a good way to use the lead event
because the bishop actually if i becomes
a target because the pawn d4 will be
hanging no
and of course if he changes his pair
bishop on what base he wants to be
better no
so
uh i've looked at this line
also of course the main attention was on
the principle game which i'm going to
show because it's a good game although
it's played on rapid but you know that
this vertana has played a lot of
incredible games especially on active
chess
and i've played also many
activities tournament and won quite a
few and i like very much discipline i
think that if you when you concentrate
on activities you can play basically
almost the same quality of games oh
almost no i'm very good quality so g3
now
everything becomes you know very
principle thing
now
are the ah black
well because okay the bishop is on a6
he's attacking the opponent but the
other is going to be on the long duo now
no so maybe there'll be some kind of
stone there is like x-rays between the
king and the bishop so arnond has
prepared rookie 8
bishop g 2 95 here is also an option
like the previous type but here we use
the same idea now we play rookie 7
defending and then we play
out of here and we follow it
98
and here if you play e3 to be able no
then to then we play 98
and the bishop
becomes like in trouble no you have to
waste time to make it you know
and just show you one line g4 to be able
to save the bishop f6 here and then we
play knight f7 and we array for e5 and
the bishop on a6 prevent the king to get
to a safer ground no and i've looked
here at f3 i think
a little bit yeah on f3 basically the
same idea you play here
and then rook d7 and you're threatening
f6 because now you're not guarding the
pawn d4
so
my opponent play
bishop g2 knight d5 and this is the
first
move that he played a new move and this
move which i think is a solid one
although after this move you can pretend
to really get opening it down the move
which i really concentrate my attention
it's a very complex vision and this in
my opinion is a principle decision is
the move 95.
here i've analyzed it wrongly how well
i'm not very sure but this is an
interesting he can force here a
repetition but of course over the road
here i have to tell you
by
what i remember
exactly in in the game some details my
opponent probably had like an hour more
on the clock so obviously this was like
a new idea for kim and it was very hard
to expect that you're going to go in all
these lights when you're hanging you
need to
look but i've analyzed this one no and
then of course i remember it quite well
but
objectively if black plays well white
probably does not have advantage but why
not very proud to go into this line so
how went
the the main game which gave me this
idea between nakubian
and
anand well it was a very good game so
here
he still wanted to keep the pair bishop
anna coburn played and bishop d2
there followed the logical e5 because
now all of your pieces are mobilized no
so you have to keep the white king in
the center e5 capturing here rook take
on e5
now not easy to hide the king e3
finally the king out of the pin
bishop c3 obviously here
the dream
for white when they play bishop g3 and
they don't play it because they feel
very happy is to achieve a draw but it's
becoming
difficult to achieve because already
black is better mobilized and he has
three against two on the queen side
and anand showed his typical great end
game technique he captured here and now
he plays
rookie now this move has an obvious idea
no you can't play rook d5
but now he wants to play rook d6 he just
moves droops on the d file and
immediately white is really into promise
here
bishop d6 rook c2 c5 already an
unplanned endgame bishop e2 it will be
good if he captures not to capture with
the king but bishop b7
problems
because now
we are gathering control of the second
leg if you castle he didn't want to
castle and then bishop c6 with a threat
bishop a4
and of course the fact that you have all
the pawns on the on the dark squares
helps no
this is like why strategically in most
of the cases is the right you know
strategic you know way to put your pawns
on the opposite color of your bishop
bishop d5
it's a bad sign of your opinion when you
have to move pawns on a flank where
you're weaker because it usually helps
the opponent of course
kubian knows that perfectly he's very
good player but here i mean he he is
forced to do that no because he is under
pressure and an obvious one he played
here bishop d five rugby c4 a small
tactical shot typical of
another and reminding the great jose
cablanca if you capture he captures back
and you're you know hanging on d1 this
check and now of course situation is
very bad and after capturing rook d3
well the game continued
some moves but here he could have
resigned because the rest was basically
very easy technique especially for for
now but not only for that i mean many
players
nothing spark can push two pawns no so
there was nothing happening till the end
of the game so a good game by
and on now my point here our game
started and like i told you i had a good
amount of time like an hour more on the
clock and it's always
helpful no
at the end my opponent was in severe
time trouble and it helped you know the
game to finish in a nice way
although this was not like the main
factor so he plays roxito obviously he
wants to defend the pawn e2 and to
castle but it gives me the necessary
time now i don't have to bother about
the square e5 i cover it immediately and
this should be like good mission because
the knight has decent outpost and i can
gain space
here
immediately g5 you can give him time
that the factors that he realize from
this mission becomes important like the
open uh chi file the pair of bishop no
you have to you know push him into some
passivity now he has to go bishop e3
because if not you're going to play g4
knight take on d4 this of course looks
unpleasant bishop p3
g4 92 during the game i've looked at
this move knight h4 but i thought that i
would play
knight
e7 and i liked my position i don't know
for example here i don't know what the
knight on h4 is doing and this is what
i liked so i was not really unhappy and
also the bishop on e3 is not impressive
so 92
and now i had to decide am i'm going to
capture material on itu but when i look
at the lies i really dislike it so i
didn't spend much time here because what
i played in the game felt really natural
if i take the ponytail i'm giving him
just what he needs time so if i take the
pawn or let me show this they take the
pawn on ito my opponent plays the
natural movie a tempo i play in knight
seven he activates the pieces now he
wants knight take on f6
you know i play for example bishop three
not the only move but after bishop f3
suddenly everything has been simplified
and where are the problems
and he was heading you know straight
straight towards uh
big time trouble so of course it doesn't
make sense you know to help your
opponent and that's why after this move
92 i play a very simple decision you
just keep controlling the position
knight e7 the knight has a good square
on d5 the bishop on e3 is basically
maybe temporarily but maybe for some
time a big white pawn so it's not really
impressive so here
and my opponent
maybe he was just like there's a joke
i'm telling you maybe he was listening
now to me then he wanted he also
disliked the bishop here on e3 and want
to activate which played a bad joke with
him so here he should have played 94
this is what i expected but still after
this move bishop c1
knight f5 i still like more my position
because i didn't see like something
really active for him no
i'm not claiming that here black has
something like real but it's easier from
practical point to play with black white
is much more difficult to come up here
with some good ideas in my opinion
so my opponent
here because he was impressed by time i
wanted you know just to use this bishop
because okay
of course not only him
i enjoy
many players enjoy very much the pair
bishop but sometimes you got obsessed
with this idea and this is what happened
here bishop f4
king b8
94 but this obviously is bad because of
the problems with the pawn structure and
quite curiously my bishop from asics
becomes much more important than his
bishop on jitto why because there is
nobody on the long digger now so he can
attack anything now i captured here
and i played knight d5 well i have to
say that the line
which
very recently when i look back at this
game
i'm not sure it even crossed my mind so
here for example a computer does not
want to play the human decision knight
d5 which even now looks to me more
natural he wants to play
knight f5 and of course okay one trick
is going to capture material but on
knight f6 you have to see rook f8
capturing here
rook h8 knight g5 knight take on d4 well
even now it looks not very logical so i
played the human move and then i saw
a similar idea but much more easier to
see you know not such long lies so
knight d5
rook c1
knight take non-f4 an important capture
with a tempo and a simple one because
you're threatening unito and here what i
saw during the game
not something special no but i like this
line because when you see it this kind
of light everything fits then you're on
the right way this is what you get you
know from years of practice when you see
that the lies you know
combined quite well together then
everything fits quite well so here the
line which i saw was knight take on f6
with the tempuno rook fade and i capture
your temple and now you play here and
want to to trap
his
knight on a7 and your proof once again
not always because i've given in the
section part of parallelism a few
of this very rare example when the
knights really become you know tired of
hearing them about themselves that they
are very bad at the edge of the boat and
they had like sweet revenge but in many
occasions just like that the knight on
the edge of the boat stands bad now
bishop e4 there'll be knight h3 with a
tempo check and if you play like let's
say e4 then you'll go here and you'll
trap the poor knight this line i like
and it show me i'm on the right way
well
when i'm showing you
now
in the finish of this end game i'm
telling you exactly what happened
because in one moment i was surprised
the patient was not easily won i thought
that here after a couple of moves with
an extra pawn it should be in my point
heading towards a very severe time
trouble he had probably like five
minutes for 15 moves something like that
i thought okay it should be very easy
but then i saw it i have to find an idea
because
you know if you don't find the right
idea to make it difficult for him and it
should be a good one then of course he
can make some frost move and then you
know the time travel is not going to be
a very important if the patient is
easier to play so my opponent here
played bishop f1 defending on e2
f5 here rookie 7 e3 and knight split
check so here of course i saw that if he
takes on h3 i take with a pawn and then
i infiltrate on the g file here
you don't have to see much no here the
bishop is clearly better than the knight
the line which during the game i liked
was that you can play this move c5
the the idea you just never to worry
about the tifo and if he captures bishop
d3 and rg2 comes with a lot of pro
problems for him so this i saw but when
he played king g2 i have to say that
before
his move
and i repeat he was in a severe time
trial i thought okay here
probably everything no i mean i'm with
the pawn up
and the king on g2 my bishop can go on
the long thing probably it should be
easy but the more i look at the patient
the more it didn't feel
very easy i couldn't find like a false
line
now for example i was looking at the
fourth line offered by a computer
and it never crossed my mind i have to
be honest so i gave check and i found
a good idea in my opinion but i taught
here like about half an hour i want to
be sure that he's not going to escape or
at least that he's
what he has to find after that it's
going to be difficult in practice and
it's it's working it has a positional
base so it gives me not something like a
hard technical position but a normal one
so here the computer wants
black to play f4
i never consider indigenous preamp this
means that he can take my pawn here with
a temple and then i play such a move and
then i play against his king
well it's a little bit too deep no i i
mean i never look at this now because
why i have to complicate my life with
this and if i take with the pawn he
plays rook f7 and start also playing you
know against the pawn yeah
now looking at it it's not bad but i'm
telling you to it never crossed my mind
so i'm i was looking here a different
other option and
what i found now i'm going to show is
something which gave me this kind of uh
good feeling that i'm on the right track
so i went with the first norm of rook
fade
knight h5 knight g5 everything is quite
frosky bishop e4
i found this move but this move is easy
no not well this was not the move that
gave me like a good feeling so bishop
take on e4 knight take on e4 and i got
quite happy when i found here if he
plays like king g2 i played c5 if he
plays king h4 then of course the king
here is quite you know bad what i
worried about in my calculation before i
played
bishop b7 in this line was what i'm
doing when he plays king a4 because now
the king is active yes he's upon down
but with such activity well he wants
them to exchange knight g3 what i liked
was that i found this move now i'm
preventing his changes my knight has
additional square g5 and there is no way
for him to really avoid like a technical
position if you place let's say f3 i can
capture play even this move then knight
g5 if you play as b4 i can play rook f7
and then of course i'm going to prepare
similar ideas like in the game because
he first played knight g3
knight g5
now in his
title he blunted but still the pitcher
in my opinion
becomes like a more technical one like
let's say b4
you can just play some normal moves
exchange and then this patient in my
opinion
has
all the looking that you should be able
to realize in the phone you have not
less activities than a point you have a
solid extra pawn why not no
and if we imagine that the rooks are
exchanged not that here it's visible how
it's going to be changed all the rooks
the knight and games are very much like
the pawn end game they have this
similarity so i was not unhappy about
this kind of position and of course
oh for example knight g2 96 like i was
looking okay here i don't know what the
96 also look
you know good for me because i'm the
active part and i still have the extra
pawn but the idea which he missed here
is not a complex one at all but it was
just because of this idea h6 that my
opponent here played immediately this
and i think that he even didn't allow me
to play the next move because he was
having like second and he had just
resigned he found even the the moment to
resign because like if he played this
move he saw that there is such an idea
no with a smaller checkmate but
then also
this idea was possible
i was looking if you play king e5
to continue with his active ideas
because this is what troubled me to find
something to prevent you know his piece
is getting active if when i found this
one i became you know quite happy with
the vision because then now if you play
ski i have f4 and there is a gain check
mating mode so this is you know a very
humble move a6 is what you know made me
to feel normal about efficient because
when i look like
20 minutes the first or 50 minutes the
first meeting and i couldn't fight like
a force when i was getting quite upset
because okay what is this like bad luck
i mean i have an extra pawn in my
opponent i mean his flag is falling and
i can't fight like a force win but all
right then i come down and find one
not out of this world but
a good practical idea and i was able to
to win this game now when we talk about
this line and let me show also a game
which was played
maybe
like half a year after this one
and i played against a very young player
which probably now she's in the usa
team and probably she has like much more
rating she she was very young when he
played in the first round of reno
and then in 2018 i was completely
inactive this was just
we had like some free free time from
bayer chess so i went for reno although
i didn't enjoy playing them because okay
it was not the same i mean the level
concentration was not the same but the
first round
that's why i'm showing you this game i
played with rochelle vu and we played
curiously this with quincy two i'm
seeing that much more followers there is
of this very solid like and i understand
why
we've already discussed it because it
gives you like
a solid pawn structure it gives you the
pair bishop why not but of course
it's risky when you play with someone
who has played it many many years and he
has like a lot of experience and this is
what showed in this game sometimes when
you play some popular lines
but you just play them because you've
seen somebody plays them you know
something but it's not exactly it
depends what kind of
variation of this line you're playing if
it's like a sharp one it can play a very
bad joke with you and i'm not only
talking about this game with
rochelle vu because she was a very young
player but in 2007 it's included i'm
going to show i played against a
grandmaster and he also in bulgarian
team championship he also lost
the game
i don't know who lost badly both of them
lost around okay 20 20 something move
so you know in this alliance we have to
to know your stuff it's no surprise
that even such a great player is the
grand petrocean the
uh who was he the ninth i think yeah he
had the ninth world champion tigran
petrossian
when he won the title against buffinic
he lost the first game in one of the
most
solid prisons possible okay i'll show
you not the game but and then he didn't
lost any more games and he won against
boutini convincingly and of course there
was no rematch this time no so this
wasn't an important element so
we continue with
uh quincy two line knight f6 g4 e693
bishop b4 and after queen c2 d5 this
time black plays the other principled
line they capture on the e5 and they
play bishop g5 a6 and now
there is one line which i always
considered you know very very solid
white well not very ambitious so here
they can expect but if black are not
very familiar even here they can get
advantage like servant quite often he
even was able once to win against tao
well we have to mention that
serrano was very
for some reason very
inconvenient opponent for tao he's got
quite a few wins which is you know
according they're just doing it should
not be like that but well in chess and
not only in chess in some other sport
there is the problem of some someone who
you play just badly against him for some
reason so he played against how this
quite dry line bishop take known f6
queen f6 and
a3 so quite curiously this was the line
in which petrossian with white
lost against but winning so just to show
the opening there are a few very few
moves so here i think it's more exact to
play castle bottoming plate c6
e3
castle and after knight
e2
but of course with white between play
rook eight
knight g3
g
and it turns out that although he played
a very slow lead line he was not quite
well familiar with this one here here he
went f3 h5
bishop p2 knight d7 and straight out
king f2 does not look uh
at all like petrocera he got like prawns
out of the opening with white and he
lost terribly the first game of course
then he showed why he is the grandparent
he won them playing very well but
it's hard to expect that in this you
know quite dry line but if you can get
prawns but this probably under the
nerves you know first game of the world
championship match now more principle is
to play bishop h4 which was played in
our game and it has a lot of history so
bishop h4 c5 here kasparov contributes a
lot but many great players has
contributed to this vision there is one
historic game for one player who for
very little and not because of his
talent didn't become a world champion
but this may be one of the most crushing
defeats i've ever seen from him and this
is karis against botwinnik so here
kelly just went into one opening
preparation by botvinnik he played a
move i'm showing in this game because it
looks a little bit like our game with
rochelle well she played rook d1 who
also looks strange
but kerry's played here long castle
and have in mind this was not a new move
it was considered when it was played in
the fronties an interesting idea but
finic has found a refutation a
positional refutation which of course
was a complete you know tactical you
know crushing defeat in the game but the
positional idea was you know just to
open up
the queen side where the king is very
vulnerable so kia bozenic has prepared
nikki's school preparation long before
computers because this game is in 1941.
nobody knew that there will be such
thing like computer so bishop taken c3
the new concept g5 and now the
importance of c take on d4 not c4 it has
been played some other moves take on d4
knight six and it turns out that the
white king cannot hide
in such a great player as karis looked
like the
you know a school boy in this game he
was completely you know demolished so e3
roxy8
bishop d3 trying to hide the king but he
can queen d7 king b1
capturing pin
problems he's losing material he played
e4 he plays quincy took knight before
so he throw knight take on e4 and you
still can cover you know this diagonal
a7 b1
here castle rook d1 b5 i think this is
the most crushing defeat i've ever seen
of caris knight d4 the back rank is a
problem and i've never seen kerris
playing with knight g1 and rook h1 not
develop here check
and after night before
he lost the game 1941.
so long castle of course
now is well known it's not good here for
example the principled line which was
played in my game from 2007 against
grandmaster nikov much younger player
and good player from from bulgaria he
played here d taken c5 the line in which
caspar of casper and now it's considered
like
the most
principled confirmation and here the
positions are usually quite sharp if you
don't know them well then it something
like in this game can happen so here i
played 94 queen a5 here this is all
theory now my opponent didn't remember
the theory and this is a bad move also
bishop e5 is not like the most popular
let me show what happened in this game
when you play sharp lights and you're
not very familiar although you're a good
player knight d4
knight take on c3
take
be taken c not the only move here for
example
just show during the game i couldn't
calculate one line that's why i captured
on c6 the line which i couldn't
calculate it is not easy but let me show
you just to see the practical i
calculated knight b5 check
here bishop take on c2 he takes my queen
and bishop take on a5
a4
because okay if b for bishop g7 of
course i have an extra piece
a4 97
b4
and okay i said okay
so for some kind of a miracle it's not
working i look at it again again in my
calculation no because it's not like two
moves it's like a line not the longest
you've seen but it's a line so i keep
calculating now check
here here
a4 b4
and i missed that i have such a
and okay you know not to miss ourselves
you've have a very good concentration
but of course obviously i didn't in here
there are some tactical details which
are not obvious especially when you're
looking like
five moves be you know before the
deposition no if you place here you have
d for
also not obvious no
i'm looking at the 15 more freedom when
he plays bishop dc you play bishop take
on b4 and then play d4
and okay the king in the center is going
to have problems so i couldn't see the
end of this line so that's why i take
beat a conceived and it was in terms of
my opponent not to see an only move his
special is not good objectively but
queen b3 is the only move which i looked
during the game instead of that he
played
a real lemon here
queen take on f5
and then knight e4 check then of course
the king is in a very bad shape no he
tried to run with the king bishop take
it here
queen f2 and then h5
and you're not just winning between
you're getting checkmate on h4 of course
if you're not giving a checkmate it's
the same i mean he can resign
but the king
has nowhere to hide so he played
king f3 queen d2 you continue with your
idea no here
bishop take on b2 now the situation is
very bad
no matter what he plays racing is bad he
played rookie to
a simple intermediate move just giving
you more time
now
if he takes with the king of course the
bishop is hanging if he plays k4 of
course you take an e5 and the rook is
hanging so captures with the queen
knight g5 here he could have resigned
but there is i mean nobody has won
anything by resigning you know that very
so i'm never you know against people who
play he tried his chance no okay queen
take on g5 is the only move if not
you're losing basically the house
everything so he took here no rock take
on b2 the problem is
not only the material
compensation is not enough the problem
is the king is still much more
vulnerable than the black king and this
is why the game ended immediately it was
like 29 moves but objectively here he
could have resigned he played h4 rookie
8
rookie 4
with a tempo not threatening rook take
on d4 so the rook on h1 is not going to
see very good days in this game
now you give back material but you get
something very real on return something
typical which we do in when we play for
example against gambits we are trying to
find the right moment to give back some
material and to get something in return
like
good pawn structure
like pair bishop or something in return
this is like typical moment playing
against gambits well sometimes we we
don't find the right moment though and
then probably we get checkmated no
so
in the end was this one and he resigned
so i had experience in this
position
but here
when i saw again this vision i was
really surprised that my young opponent
and usually young players know quite
well theory
that's for sure but here my younger
opponent played rook d-1
and again here this is just the lack of
energy i couldn't i i told you this move
is bad i mean he
clearly has this feeling of being bad
but i couldn't calculate not a very
complex line so the first of course
intention was just capture on d4 and i
was looking at the lies but i couldn't
make them work so what i was looking i
was looking at taking on d4 knight six
with the tempo queen a4 this was the
only move which worried me because
everything else i mean there is no need
to mention it here
what we are going to look i mean it's
ridiculous no
other move okay going back d4
looks very bad i mean with such a
development you're not going to survive
that's for sure so what troubled me was
the move queen a4 and somehow i
convinced myself although the game is
not bad at all but i can responsibility
it's not clear
and
it's a little bit like i wish for
thinking because here even bishop a5 is
not bad with bishop b6 but the more
straightforward is just this one you
take on c3 your castle the rook is under
attack you play g5 knight e4 and
probably
white is not going to survive because
actually you can survive with all the
king's side on the back rank no but okay
i thought okay i can miss myself he's
not
so clear so i played knight six not a
bad move now my opponent
should have played d taken see if shifa
also doesn't have like a very good look
but she played e3 and now okay this
piston was not difficult to play and
because you have a very easy play
she's going to have trouble you know to
really finish development and she tried
to she'd do some kind of a miracles to
try but it was a little bit too much now
you're going to see she played bishop e2
because of knight f3 she was worried
about bishop g4 and capturing here and
check and because you capture with a
bishop let me show you play check
and then g5
and okay this looks very bad because
just to mention my detail you can even
get checkmate on e1
which is a bad sign or if the opponent
starts straight out of the opening with
black having checkmates on the back rank
that something has gone not very well
and also of course after knight f3 we
can play bishop g4 okay i've just shown
you but there was like this possibility
another way bishop b5 look after bishop
it was what he played yeah i played g5
it looked to me a little bit easier to
play in rook 8 so the main idea here
that this is what i want to show after
bishop g3 knight e4 if he tries to
finish development with this move
this is what i meant he could it's
actually not happening because you play
bishop f5
threatening a discard she gets the queen
jose please and you play rookie
so how is going to you know to be able
here to uh castle is a mystery because
she can castle because bishop take on c3
knight take on g3 roktek
so i was sure that this is not not good
and okay you can play something like f3
here but it's like out of a not very
good life here of course i was happy
with blackpish i mean
they're good
so my point here sawing this travel
because obviously she's a talented
player and probably she's going to
become a very good player i don't know
but when all the good
options were looking set for her she
tried to the frosting she tried to
invent something which is not on the
broad and it was a little bit too much
now she played bishop f3 again a move
with she's already because he developed
but now she plays bishop f3 with this
wishful team that you're going to have
time to play 92 and short castle of
course you don't have enough time to do
that and probably black has many ways to
exploit that on in the game i thought
and i hope i found one
interesting idea based on a small
tactical hotel but it's not the only one
but it feel to me like the nature i
played bishop f5 queen b3 and now the
move which i played i repeat it's not
the only one
the computer probably we want something
different but i like my move i played a5
because it makes sense here to use you
know that the queen
keeps doing moves and you're not
developing pieces so why not use this
obvious tactical element i want to play
a4 and i want to trap the queen
i mean if you play knight two i play a4
then i start winning material no the
queen doesn't have any space so i think
that here they are forced to play a4
okay if you give up your bishop like it
happened in the game then what you have
played in the opening is really hard you
know to give an answer to this because i
mean it looks quite bad so my opponent
played a4
and now the of a5
on this simple tactical tell you play
queen b6 and because of the tempo thread
bishop take on c3 you win even more time
here of course i was absolutely sure
that the prison is completely hopeless
my opponent play bishop take on e4
bishop take and play f3 well
i mean out of a
difficult situation now if you play for
example f corn f3 and knight f3 you just
capture take on d4 and everything is
over or king f1 is hanging on d4 so f3
but alright this is like a sign of
complete failure
knight take on d4 here if you want such
a games when your point clearly has
failed you have to just make yourself
just to calculate till the end not
complex line at all you're just garlic
have like the normal concentration
because all the signs are on the board
it should be finishing soon no because
i mean the player of your opponent
has all the marks had been completely
off so knight take on d4 with the tempo
there is no tricks here i mean if he
plays something like bishop c7 i even
look at such trick bro it's ridiculous
no this one you can even play such a
move no
and then you're threatening the queen
and you're threatening this coward check
with the bishop so no tricks are
possible here rook taken d4 quintet on
d4 and here all the lies were pretty
simple because
i mean
the king the white king is in a very
delicate situation so that's why it's
normal that he's going to lose material
not not the country if you place 92
queen d3
capture and d4
and okay you're going to have an extra
exchange no
queen d5 you play rook d8 if you place
queen d1 you just capture here nothing
more to calculate on bishop f2 if she
has played in this situation no if you
play bishop to some kind of intermediate
move it's actually not helping much you
play the same move and d4
game over no need to i even calculate
this but okay you have some other option
you play here this is just showing how
bad is his pitching when you promote
another queen
but this is just you know
not really necessary my opponent played
take on e4
queen take on e4 check and now
if the king goes like on f1 then he
becomes a major target but if you cover
here and then you have queen b1 check
not the only movement but queen blue eye
is very simple no you have to cover
like that and then you'll capture here
with a tempo
and all your take can see okay this of
course he
resides with bishop take on c3 but if
you play queen 2 just this check because
now not only are checking on the back
rank but the knight on c3 is hanging
other moves also not helping at all i
mean
king d1 hanging on g2 no need for any
command
king f2 bishop c5 of course so king f1
and you have queen e3 check
now
he could have resigned here she played a
couple of more moves like king f2 bishop
c5 or king a1 you're just giving
checkmate no so
here d4 and after the move queen d1 i
gave check on a5 and okay she's
not only having material disadvantage
but probably she's going to get
checkmated very soon so this was mainly
because of a bad opening
and that's why especially knowing
sometimes you don't have the information
that it can backfire quite badly so i
played one game
and the next one i want to show you let
me see how we're going to yeah maybe we
have time at least to show you so i've
played in two consecutive years
and i've played this against many very
good players so i played
twice in 2000 and 2008 against
a solid grandmaster from usa this one of
my pet lies in the scotch with white so
knight f3 knight six
here this line
we play in different versions but we
always play this line of the scorch this
queen f6
and c3
knight e7 and instead of kasparov bishop
c4 now they start playing even bishop b5
i always like to play g3 and i know it
quite well for both colors
maybe object does not give anything
special but you have to know it very
well so i was quite so and we played
this like i've told you with the same
appoint 2007 and 2008 and i scored two
very good victories okay decent let's
say
but our surprise went many years ago
like in 2018 at the tournament of reno
and the same one i played the first
round with chevoux i saw this line well
probably by chance because probably my
opponent didn't know that i used to play
this time and also we work in the same
club but okay he do not get the
impersonator he played e4 e5 and this
time he played it against me
you know with white
but okay when you play one line
quite often and you have huge speed
usually it's supposed that you know how
to play with the other
pieces so when i saw this move g3 i have
a recollection here of quite a few hours
looking dispersion so here the
difference between playing d5
immediately and playing h5 h3 and then
d5 is in small details i'm not going to
bother with all this theoretical
information but it's important to
include in some sharp lines the
inclusion of h5 and h3 are in black
favor when you really know your things
like the opening stuff in this ratio in
detail my opponent was not such a
experts after h5 he surprised me here
with some
of which i've never looked in now i have
to wear knight c2 well knight c2 with h5
already provided the pawn probably go to
h4 and having no problem for space here
why
the basic idea of the scotch is to play
for space
like against coach
because i've played
you know mainly with white but of course
playing if i had to play quite a few
games with with black
like i've almost exclusively played
bishop t5 in normal games like standard
games and in blitz like many years ago
when i say i played all the time knight
f6 and after capturing on c6 b take on
c6 e5 queen e7 quinito knight d5 c4 i
always played knight b6 on the eighth
move
because it was
less so well known but i've played
many many
good games in this with white because in
the scotch game when you play against
knight f6
and bishop c5 the most logical and
normal conclusion after knight f6 even
the greater anatolic carbon in his
matches with kasparov experience problem
because you have a worse pawn structure
yes you compensate with a
development but it's a very thin margin
no because if you just play one
imprecise move what remains is this you
know long-term factor the pawn structure
so that's why it's not easy to play with
bishop c5
you usually don't have problems with the
pawn structure with black but it's about
space so also if you're a little bit
imprecise you're going to get with a
pission
what they say solid position but it's
also a very a slight margin between
solid and passive so it's a problem so i
like to play this mission which the main
strategic idea is to play for space yeah
you have to be also
precise but i get quite a few very good
games okay good games let's see very
good with white so here after 92 i knew
that this mission can be
can be dangerous at all so the problem
is how you can keep the three results
from the broad
using your experience so here i played
bishop e3 knight e3 but curiously during
the game i saw both of these moves but i
thought that they are strategically a
little bit too much and then when i
analyzed it come i thought yes they look
a little bit strange b6 looks strange d6
also because it makes even worse the
pawn stacks no at least in this case
you take towards the center
but you don't give any space to the
opponent this is also true and this
develops the bishop no so they make
sense when you take on e3 you keep your
pawn structure solid intake but you help
the opponent on the knight it goes to e3
it's good that the other knight
has its most natural square taken away
but i saw that here of course black has
no problems at all what worried me if i
can keep you know the game alive because
my appointment with this solid play show
that he has no opening ambitions
but i had some ambitions to have like
the three results from the broad so i
capture here
d6 bishop g2 h4
it doesn't matter if the knight goes to
a3 you play bishop dc and it casts so
long and it's practically easier to play
this mission with black they don't have
anything special it's logical why white
have not done anything bad but still
you're going to see it was about
who is going to get a better control of
the dark squares because it's quite
logical this strategic team because
there is no dark squares on the board so
this is like an important and of course
you can allow him here because he has
wasted quite a bit of time not play
knight c2 knight take on e3 to get any
more space
that the minimal you can give him so
bishop d7 queenito a long castle a long
castle if he plays f4 of course we have
the strategic team now fighting for the
dark square g5 and that's why he has to
be also careful and not to play some
seldom active move no along castle
and now of course g5 this is something
in branch and i thought that here he
have to be careful no
and my opponent here true to his tower
he's a solid player but usually in more
occasions
you know than than the country so
strategically prone by some you know
using tactical details and he also tried
this here here i was looking i told it
instead of 95 what he paid which is like
a responsible move i thought knowledge
goes to play like rook f1 and try to
play f4 which of course i can avoid it
he's going to player 4 but i thought
that this vision
is around equal
but at least he has to be a little bit
more careful not because
i mean black can attack in some
occasions more you know some target you
know what they have temporary the h file
here for example this is a big
positional mistake because it gives away
the dark squares probably it's an equal
operation but i prefer to play it with
black probably this is just you know
my feeling maybe just quite
nothing special so after g5 my opponent
found a tactical idea and he tried to
solve
the
possible future problem strategic by
some tactical idea typical of his style
95. now the idea behind this one and i
was characterizing durian but i was not
you know very fond here to sacrifice
material later i found if i sacrifice
material there's like one detail which
can help but even now i'm not very fond
of you know taking the pawn what do i
mean let me show you if i take 95 here
95 my point i want to play
94
and the idea of this move is to make a
double attack and of course not
immediately queen e3 because there is
queen take on f2
this time black has the tactical shot
and then knight d3 but he plays knight
default and this is obvious to see over
the world and then he plays queen e3 now
during the game i
looked only in this king beard and i saw
it here i have compensation but
i mean just to give a pawn in the end
when you don't really need it to give it
was a little bit not
i was not happy with that now later on i
saw it maybe when you're going to play
an end game with the compensation maybe
the computer here i saw his logic is
right try to keep at least the king you
know closer and you play b6 and you put
another pawn on dark square still
oh yeah of course here you are
threatening rook take on h1 but still
not
very much convinced of that well maybe
he's
understands better no so i decide not to
give up material but try at least with
the move i choose to prevent f4 to make
you know his decision much tougher so
that's why the queen goes here on e6
because now if you play f4 you are
hanging on the
pin along the e file so queen e6 maya
point of course
97 97 i light here for black because
immediately the queen on e6 has you know
an important faction it attacks on a2 so
it gives you time and this is something
good and if you defend for example here
you play g for
and you
now you have strategic places no because
okay always he's going to have problems
with the bishop on g2 and
the square e5 and you can press him on
the h file on the e file it's not like
something you'll be very happy with this
piece my point continued with this line
queen c4
and after the move queen g6 not the only
move here for example i can explain what
prevented me to play g4 maybe during the
game i told it okay the material is not
getting much i saw bishop g2 and then
rook h1 but if you continue this line
this probably was not a sign of good
concentration which
speaking of 2018 we i already explained
it and i was
completely inactive player then
which means not a good concentration but
if you play bishop g2 kj through h1
after the chain
still
black is having good concentration
because most of the white pieces are
quite awkward well i missed this detail
and played
queen g6
and here for example i think that both
of us during the game nobody saw such a
line which was offered by an engine and
it looks quite inhuman like e5 here with
idea to sacrifice here and to give this
double deck and at the end of the line
they achieve sort of equality but okay
this is a little bit like you know
fantasy during the game i was looking at
f4 and i saw queen f6 and i have some
pressure
later on i saw it probably it was better
to play queen a6 but in this endgame i
thought that he has to defend
because i have the h file no so i was
not unhappy about this vision my point
played f4 here
and after capturing on f4 and then he
captured with the pawn well i've already
explained this mission that i wanted to
play queen f6 if he captures with a pawn
now queen h6 later on i thought it is
even better now so capturing here
knight take on d5 and here at this stage
of the i was quite happy with my play
maybe a little bit too happy because
this
relaxation prevent me to see something
simpler than although it was from
practical the reason it was not really
needed here i expected him to take to
capture with the pawn he surprised me
very much with the capturing between
which in my opinion is bad so if he
captures with the pawn i intend to play
97 and this mission i think still
objectively maybe it's equal but it's
easier to play with white
he has to defend his pawn i mean i don't
like prison when the bishop stares at
his own pawn on d5 and he has problems
with some pawns like the on the file
but much better compared to the game
because in the game after 25
i play
queen f6 queen a6 here
probably was more precise because it
activate the piece even easier but okay
i have seen queen f6 for some reason i
got a little bit like looking only at
this one
now he can't give away the e5 square
it's positionally bad rook form and now
i activate my pieces in a very
natural way you know not okay shade he
has to go back queen d3 bishop g4
everything is going
quite smoothly and now my opponent
played queen b5 well there are some
possibilities like to play e5 mandela
really convincing and after queen b5
this was the first moment when i looked
here at rook c3 but i don't find it
necessary no
and i think probably i was right because
white to complicate life so i played a6
and when my opponent
played queen g5 in an already difficult
situation when he played queen g5
the reason why which i didn't found not
a very complex although not
obvious one was that the other thing
which i played in the game looked to me
like a very easy technical win so that's
why i didn't pay enough attention to
this tactical rook take on c3 which of
course i saw but i thought okay why to
pay much then here
here and after bishop b6 i just missed
that he can defend
the knight on d2 and also the stronger
threat bishop take on a2
and it may look a little bit you know
surprising but there is no defense here
if you play here bishop take on a2
you can give one check even you have
even checked but still
they are losing like knight b3 queen d3
and
the rook is hanging if they play rook c1
well maybe i should have paid an
attention because it's really like a
false win
but here i'm not hard on myself because
i think that if you look at such a
position this end game queen take on g5
knight and e5 this should be a
very easy technical one end game
mikosuki already has
quite a few pawn weaknesses all of your
opinions are more active so i thought
this should be like a walk in the park
which really happened in the game
although i don't have you know the end
of the game because it was like
in one moment and it was like half an
hour and my opponent normally you know
he played like i think i had like two
extra pawns and looking i'm going to
show the the moves which happened
because the patient is beyond in my
opinion easily technically one so here
after 95 my opponent play rook g1
rook h2
bishop g2 knight d3
knight f4 bishop p6 and after knight b3
the logic of c5 not the only move of
course you can play knight e3 but why
tuhari here with material when i don't
see what he can move no
c5 and then what i remember at the end
of the game that i had to realize two
extra pawns it was like
he created some kind of uh tactical
defense but it was completely desperate
i mean the technical phase was actually
just after the time control you have to
keep like
like a normal concentration nothing out
of this world and then it should be
already twenty like that the only thing
is that for some reason here i have lost
the end of the game but nothing
interesting happened no i mean why just
uh black just have to realize uh super
easy and technical with the more
material you know and it went without
any surprise here the main thing which i
want to show that
you have to be careful sometimes not to
have the bad luck to play a line against
the point which
especially in this line
has accumulated a lot of experience
because it can be backfired very badly
but here it may
happen more often here for example in
the usa open tournament because like i
thought you have
almost no time to prepare well now maybe
with the computer they can you know in
15 minutes look a little bit
what the point plays but it's actually
here the schedule is very tough here
when i was playing
like
i was not inactive well there were
tournaments we should play three games
in a day this is very tough i mean
really really tough so you have to be
prepared and with a lot of energy and
stamina because on the third game you
usually start missing some detail that's
for sure
so i hope you like it thank you i want
to share with you some of the practical
experience and you see that about the
opening operation it's about you know
working on your stuff and trying you
know to keep the opponent always with a
little bit of surprises but also for
having something like a basic repertoire
and to decide for yourself if you're
going to be like a very narrow
repertoire or you want to play more
options which means that some of the
offline should be like basic like the
neem 2 indian
depending on for example you play
e4 e5 if you play e5 then for example
the italian you have to know it in some
other basic openings no
so i hope you like it and
i also enjoyed and all the best hope to
see you soon
bye bye
[Music]
you